>>David: The essence of King Middle
School is giving kids, all kids,
a very purposeful way of engaging
in complex ideas, concepts,
challenges and curriculum.
It's about taking curriculum,
which is often so dry --
it's about taking it and finding how
that actually fits into the context
of the real world, giving kids
opportunities to work with people
who actually work in real
disciplines in the world,
not just academic disciplines
but work in applied science
or in applied art or in applied
design, and creating a context
in which they can explore that while
they build both meaningful skill sets
and develop -- they develop
accurate comprehension of curriculum,
but they're doing it all within
the context of real work.
It's a tricky model, because it
means that in order to pull that off,
you need a group of
six or seven adults
who are those kids' primary teachers.
You need those adults to
understand the big picture
of where they want
that learning to go.
They have to be able to
engage with the community
and find the right connection, and
they have to be able to think about,
"So, I'm a field biologist.
Well, what is it that
a field biologist does?
Who's the right field biologist to
get in here to work with our kids,
and if we take what a field
biologist does, what does that look
like when a seventh-grader does it?
How do we modify it so it's
a seventh-grader activity
so that seventh-graders can really
do that well and accomplish this sort
of appearance of the same goals
that a real field biologist
would engage in."
>>We adopted the expeditionary
learning model at the beginning
in 1993, and the laptop
initiative began in 2001 or 2002.
By the time the laptop
initiative came out,
we were already pretty well-versed
in what project-based
learning looked like.
We still had a lot of work to do.
We always have a lot of work to do in
this area, but that gradual process
of change meant that it was a change
that meant changing the culture
of the school, changing
the culture of the --
changing the way educators
thought about doing their work,
changing the structures within
the school as we began to see
that certain things are too difficult
to expect in a lockdown structure,
finding ways to open
that structure over time.
We have summer planning
institutes, which we've been doing
for 15 years now, where almost the
entire staff comes in for three
or four days in the
summer, works together
around planning learning expeditions,
critiques each other's work,
talks about common
resources we could share.
We look at different kinds of
products people are making.
We talk about the learning that
could happen in those products.
So, we've been doing
that for a long time.
We've had a celebration of
learning for 13 or 14 years now,
where at a given point in the
year at the end of the year we put
out all the learning
that kids have done,
all the products that kids have done.
We invite educators
from around the country
to come and look at that work.
Our kids all talk about
their learning.
That's been going on for a long time.
>>By the time those laptops came out,
we already had done deep
multimedia work with kids,
so we felt quite ready for them.
In fact, we were feeling held back
by not having laptops
before they showed up.
So, when they came it was like
we hit the ground running,
and when I say "we,"
I mean some of us.
So, some of us in the school
were doing the kinds of things
that we felt like over time we
wanted to see everybody doing,
and that's one of the great things
about the leadership
structure at King.
It's extremely flexible,
like everything else.
Most of us do two or three
things and nobody cares
if somebody else is doing the
same thing as another person.
Everybody's overlapping and working
together to get the job done.
When it came to looking at
the best practice of learning
and teaching here at the
school, nobody thought
about it first and did it second.
Everybody here had ideas that were
driven by values and sort of hunches
about how learning should work,
and then we started doing that
and then we started to catalog
our success, and that cataloguing
of success led to looking at
what were the practices that made
that possible and then
institutionalizing those practices
over time through a process
of recording and documenting
and doing professional
development around that work.
>>The way traditional schools are
set up is they're training children
and young adults to
become mini-professors.
You've got your mini-professor
of English
and you've got your
mini-professor of science
or your mini-professor of math.
And that's just the model and
the paradigm we're working with,
but that paradigm doesn't
really suit the needs of kids
or the world anymore today, so
one problem that we're facing is
that most schools don't even
realize that they're working
from within a modeled framework.
That doesn't really
make sense anymore.
Then we look out and we think about,
well, what's an alternative model?
And we think, well, we'd like it
to be more like the real world,
and a lot of schools have said, "We'd
really like our school to be more
like the real world," but they
break down around structures
that would support
that within the school.
What it takes in a lot of
schools is a kind of heroic effort
by a few people to pull off these
complex learning experiences
for kids, and we found here
that heroic effort is great once
and a while, but it's a burnout.
So, unless you find a way to
support that within the structure
of the school itself, you're going to
burn out trying to turn your school
into something that's
really meaningful for kids.
>>Most schools are divided into
40- or 50- or 60-minute blocks.
They might think they're progressive
if they do 80-minute blocks,
but that's not what
we're talking about.
We're talking about a schedule
here at King Middle School,
where a team of five or six experts
in learning, your teachers, can say,
"In order to pull off this particular
project at this particular stage,
in order to make the workflow happen
that we need to accomplish with kids,
we need to design a whole
new schedule this week."
And that's what we have
here at King Middle School.
There aren't any bells.
Nobody actually knows where
anybody is most of the time,
but that's the way real work
happens, and we all know that.
If we're working in the world and
we're in any kind of engineering
or design process or we're
editing movies or making sounds
or we're doing whatever
it is that people do,
nobody stops after 40
minutes, puts everything down
and goes on to do something else.
So, flexible schedules is very key.
Another piece, which is around
time and time management:
Schools need to absolutely
commit the time for planning
and collaborative planning
within the schedule framework
so that all teachers
can work together
to integrate the curriculum pieces
and do the basic nuts and bolts
and workflow planning to make
something complicated happen
for 80 kids over the
course of 8, 10, 12 weeks.
It's not easy.
It takes a lot of teamwork,
which is also not easy,
and it also takes a absolute
commitment on the part
of the school administration and the
leadership to carve out that time
and make it sacred
for teacher planning.
>>Another piece of the framework
that's critical is you need
to have the right resources
in students' hands,
and for us that's been
a variety of things;
not least important has been
the 1-to-1 Laptop Initiative.
Now, I wouldn't say it's
the most important thing.
I would say it's among
the most important things,
because you also need to have the
right reading resources for kids,
so you have to be able to identify
developmentally appropriate reading
materials for all kids within topics,
or else you don't really have
a topic that will fly for kids.
But at the same time, if you don't
give them a tool like a laptop,
a real, professional tool that
professionals would use all the time
in any field, then you've taken
away the opportunity for kids to act
like real professionals or to
produce real professional products.
>>Anybody who's spent time working
with computers knows they're
actually more complicated
than people would have you believe.
It's difficult to know how to manage
the workflow through a project.
We have a teacher here in the
building whose job is to work
with all seventh-graders and
to manage that sort of workflow
with kids and teach them
what that looks like.
And, in fact, we've kind of
spread that out in a lot of ways,
creating lots of different production
houses within the school so that
as kids pass through different
curriculum areas, teachers can rely
on experts in production
within their own team framework
to help them build
those kinds of projects.
So, I would call that knowhow.
It's one thing to have the
resources, but you totally need
to have the knowhow
built into the building.
>>We go through a process as staff
where we critique each other's work,
and that's a model for how we
do our work with kids as well.
We know that getting to the best
product for all kids means a period
of revision and assessment, formative
assessment, looking at kids' work,
and when I say "looking at kids'
work," I don't mean adults looking
at kids' work exclusively.
I mean kids looking at
kids' work based upon models
that they've already
looked at and seen.
Our teachers produce -- we
call them "exemplar models"
of the products our kids are going to
make before the kids actually do it.
And so, often the kids look
at what a teacher's made
and they say, "You know what?
I get it and I think I
could do that better."
And that whole process leads
to our kids also beginning
to define the criteria of what a
high-quality product would look like,
and that's not informal.
We formalize that.
We design rubrics and
create rubrics with our kids
that define what quality would
look like, and then our kids work
to meet their own definition
of quality.
That's very collaborative,
so our kids work together.
They do peer editing,
and near the end
of an expedition sometimes
there's a week or six
or seven days set aside just for
looking at drafts and revisions,
drafts and revisions, to get to a
high-quality final product with kids.
>>All kids learn in different ways,
and we know that all kids
learn at different speeds.
And what we've tried to do is
ask teams of teachers to think
about how they can bring different
kinds of media and different kinds
of representations of learning into
the products that they're making.
We've often asked teams to
think about if you're going
to do this piece around
producing a document, for example,
with the Taking Care
of Business expedition,
we've got all those kids
producing business plans
and making little businesses
and they're writing these things
that're official little business
plans at the same time that down
in Joe Farrell's room
producing a piece of music.
And, for kids who love music,
that might be the hook,
and for kids who love writing,
which my daughter's a kid
who loves writing,
that's the hook too.
You might think of it a
little bit as like a pop song.
We need to make sure we have the
hook in there for all different kinds
of kids and all the
different kinds of learners,
and we're very aware of that.
We often ask that all
expeditions include a piece of art
that kids are producing, and we
make sure that the output media
of the product can hold a variety
of different kinds of media
so kids can feel proud
of the piece they drew.
If they're not as proud
of their writing,
they might think this
is a great piece of art
that supports it that they made.
So, bringing in the capacity of kids
to represent curriculum in a variety
of media, in a variety
of intelligences just makes it more
possible for kids to feel successful.
>>We make sure that our kids feel
like they're a part of a team,
so our kids -- they actually
don't call them "teams" here.
We call them "houses," and our kids
have the same houses for two years
in a row, the same teachers.
We do looping, and
there's a strong commitment
that every child will be known
by at least one significant adult
in the school, so we have crews,
and a crew is only about 10,
8 to 12 kids big, and that
8-to-12-kid group meets once a week
with their crew leader,
who's one of the faculty.
It's not necessarily their teacher,
and those groups of kids do things
like initiatives together
with the teacher,
all kinds of different experiences,
and they also manage the
learning-portfolio process
with that particular crew teacher.
And then we have teams that
are just totally committed
to kids treating each
other respectfully.
Our kids go out and
do community service.
Lots of our teams, whether
it's expedition time or not,
do volunteer work in the community.
We take our seventh-graders.
Our whole seventh grade goes
out camping for three days,
and it's all based around
teamwork, communication.
We have a ropes course in our gym.
We're very happy to have
competitive experiences for our kids,
but we also try to balance
that with collaboration
and compassion and care for our kids.
We teach those things explicitly, and
I think when you come into King --
I think everybody says this --
the place does just
have a really good vibe.
It feels really good.
It's not cliquey.
Kids all get along with one
another, and it's remarkable.
>>For more information on What Works
in Public Education
go to edutopia.org